[Applause]
listen you can't hold me down
hey what's up welcome back to winners on
a wednesday i'm sat here with jesse and
q
professional rugby players killing it in
the property world
we've been working together for a few
years and they've done some
massive massive things so hey guys thank
you so much for coming to the channel i
appreciate you so much
ah thanks for having us on exciting time
so we've been we've been connected a few
years now
yeah yeah um it'd be great to just kind
of hear backstory because
you know you're you're totally full out
rugby players playing professionally but
also doing property on the side
so how did it stop how did that how did
this how did this all begin
um i think it just started with coming
across some of your
content online um and also
um you know finding out that you you
believe in jesus
and um i believe in jesus so it kind of
like oh okay
what's this guy doing that makes him
financially free and then i went through
a few videos and then and i think there
was this crash course
and i went around and i asked all the
boys in the team oh do you want to come
with me
there's a crash course in britain now
the name i'm gonna name the boys
no no
and um just happened to be that that q
was the only one
that was keen he was the only one that
was smart enough to go
let's make it happen yeah and um he was
pretty
like what what is it what is it so i
started sending videos
and some of the first couple of videos
was about lease option agreements and
winners on a wednesday
and i said also if we if we do this
we're gonna become
one of those students or winners
trust me man so um that's how it kind of
started
just um sharing um a conversation
and then cues got his side no yeah
because i think wolf jessica's really
optimistic and
like he's got loads of energy and um
yeah i think when he kind of mentioned
it to the boys
i think that was just one of those
things the boys kind of brushed aside
but um
when he mentioned it to me i was like oh
yeah sounds interesting and so we met at
um
we met for coffee and he just kind of
explained everything to me and he goes
well
if you're interested watch these videos
so it was like youtube videos of
yourself
you guys watch these videos and then um
he's got a crash course
um i think it was like the following
week or two weeks
and then we can book to go on on the
crash course so yeah i watched the
videos
and then they got got me hulk day and
then yeah we booked to
to go to the crash course but um not
knowing that
when we got there was the wrong crash
course that we bought for
yeah we um we booked four crash course
but we got there
and um yeah we actually booked for crash
course that was happening
in two weeks and we got to like we got
there and it was the wrong crash course
but
like anyone mate here knows everyone
knows you managed to block you managed
to blag your way
we let you in right we didn't turn you
away the people's turn
yeah so okay cool so so that's great and
something as well really interesting is
you came down to the crash course what
year was that was it like 2018 2019
2018 18 or 19. i think it was 2019.
yeah i remember that i remember meeting
you guys i remember we did a selfie
together
yeah yeah jesse was like i'm going to be
on winners wednesday but i mean for me
it's a great
you know it's a great honor to work with
professional sports people
um you know and and i've been really
fortunate to be able to coach
footballers and
and different sports people but rugby
players it's it's an interesting knee so
hopefully you'll be the first to kind of
like break
you know break the rugby um you know
really really open up to book players
how
what teams do you play for and how does
it work
trying to balance your property business
and
learn about property from scratch like
when you guys came to me it's not like
it's it's not like you already had a
property business you were like we're
just looking at getting into this
how does that work that is it a bit of a
conflict
time management how does it work uh well
i think it works quite well because um
jesse's full-time plays for casper
tigers is full-time and i
and i'm part-time so all my trainings at
night
so i train three four times a night a
week at night
but he trains during the day so anything
that
um jess can't do i pick up yeah yeah and
then
once i go to training then he comes and
takes over so the fact that you guys
look like partners
yeah yeah and you said what was the name
of your property company trying property
try line property what did you call it
that because
[Music]
kind of um signifies that like it's the
goal to score try and run you so that's
that's good to get property and get
deals online yeah would you don't try
yeah you smashed out the park okay cool
so i guess it helps
because sometimes in the sports world
it's like you've got to be
all in or nothing right yeah so i know
we
with yourselves your your teams and that
they want 100 commitment
i guess what you're saying is because
you've you've partnered up yeah
that that helps yeah yeah um so you
almost missed a game
coming to some of my training yeah
um you know it was a bit different for
me you know at that time i was away from
my family
yeah my family stayed in australia for a
certain amount of time
but i promised myself that i wouldn't
waste any time now that i don't have to
do kids drop off
i don't do kids pick up and i wanted to
make my time valuable and be intentional
with it
so intentional was reading a book or
taking action and then going to a course
and it just happened to be that was the
crash course and it was on our game day
so me and you rushed out to bremen on
game day got there
um things happened and then i said bro
we gotta go and then he was like nah
this is important
it's five minutes so i ended up going
straight from the crash course
straight to the bus and then on the bus
straight to our game
and um yeah we happened to come the next
day did you win
no ah but i'm playing well
yeah okay it's funny
and then you came back to the crash
course after the game yes
the next day the next day yeah the next
day yeah
you came for david too yeah okay so talk
to me what happened then so
so you know you guys your full-time
rugby
you're playing for castleford's great
team i need to come and watch you by the
way
do you come to the jungle it's called
the jungle i need to come to the jungle
and um okay so so you decide you're
going to set a property company together
what happened then well i think we just
want to try and um
kind of prove that um we're going into
probably something that's
quite new to us and we wanted to kind of
prove that um
we kind of it's cliche but kind of set
our minds to
to this new venture that we're going
into that um
we could prove to everyone that we'll
kind of start from scratch and
kind of build from there yeah and um
yeah property is
one venture that we we we kind of
thought okay
this could get us the financial freedom
that we want to
we want to get to um yeah especially
after rugby
because you're you're you're like not a
young rugby player
oh no i know i i look young
yeah i'm 37 this year but like i said
before the secret is
don't make tackles so if you want to
play you want to play longer don't make
tackles so
yeah no yes yeah quite old like i've
just signed a
two-year contract so right like um i'm
gonna be playing next year but yeah
like like i said before rugby is not a
long career so you
it's like 10 to 15 years that you you
kind of play for
and you got to try and find something on
the side to try and once rugby's furnace
to um fall back on and
yeah properly is what we're trying to do
yeah but yeah i mean it's funny as well
because
most of these types of sports whether
it's football rugby whatever um
it's sure and you can make very big
money yeah but it but
but but it's sure and i think it's smart
to say actually we're going to invest
that
we're going to invest our money or in
your case we're going to we're going to
invest other people's money and we're
going to we're going to do it no money
down which
we'll get on to how you've done that um
so your first deal then when did you
because i know you quite quickly you
guys
bought a house quite quickly after the
crash course which is just a
straightforward
buy rent out property yeah what's the
roi on that
yeah so that was a house that um um
as soon as the course finished i learned
how to do return of investment
and then um i did the numbers on this
house and i went wow this
this is gonna be 36 return of investment
and i thought that was
very good i thought because i remember
you saying you don't touch anything
under 20 yeah so i thought i beat you
because i got 36. you beat me
yeah yeah and like just to get
over the line my wife wasn't here so i
bought it without her permission
so she wasn't i just ran like this and i
bought a house
i said yeah i've got the keys today
but um look in terms of like the passive
income was the big thing for me um
you know getting about 400 quid passive
income without doing anything and it's a
cheap house as well it was a cheap house
i just thought wow look at this and then
yeah the chai line just all started with
me and q picking
what strategy we wanted to do yeah it
was it was service accommodation
service departments yeah because the
thing is as well we buy to let
you can buy a house but you have to put
down quite a lot of money and then the
the rent
if you just rent out the normal y you
have to have a lot of houses
to to give you an income level where you
can comfortably retire
so you decided you didn't want to put
down your own money anymore
yeah right you wanted to be smart yeah
you wanted to use something like rent to
rent or something
or join ventures and secondly you want
to use you wanted to do service
accommodation
so tell me cute what does service
accommodation mean and why did you
choose that strategy so
yeah so the rent-to-rent service
accommodation is where you
agree um a rent with the landlord so
you're taking the
the rent their property off the landlord
and renting it up but then
you then put it on um on the market on a
nightly basis so
um so that could be on booking.com or
airbnb and then
you kind of try to do the numbers on you
know the occupation rate
um for for the month and then
you you kind of do your your research in
the area and then you decide
where you're going to take the house on
or not yeah yeah so basically you're
controlling it
and then your your cash flowing from it
and some people think
you know rent to rent surely that's for
people that haven't got any money
they're just getting started
but it's like well actually some of the
biggest companies in the world use
control instead of ownership
yeah like amazon uber airbnb they don't
own their hotels their taxis their store
they control it and they benefit off the
cash flow so talk me through your first
rent to rent deal how you find it what
happened when you did it
and how it panned out um well it was
more networking if i didn't really put
myself out there and tell everyone
i'm a property investor i want property
one of the local election agencies
reached out to me you know logic letting
shout out let's go
um yeah look they came up to me and they
said look i've got this house that
that could potentially fit what you're
doing and it will allow
service combination and it's furnished
and i said wow okay
where is it so we don't have due
diligence on the area
um q was in the deal but his wife didn't
know
secret why is it for you guys what is it
for you guys we'll get on to that
but um look the the house was beautiful
um i thought it was a good um
location in terms of the premier inn
that was in the local area
and i just did a circle and i said 5k
radius within that and that house was in
the 5k so it ticked that box
and then i thought if i could take one
room from premiere in
each night this would work and um that's
how we but we really didn't have our
numbers at that stage
there's a combination of right because i
know q is more the the due diligence
numbers guy
you're kind of the networker yeah um
like jesse's the guy
putting pictures on on instagram just be
you know
samuel's course or whatever i'm in
property now watch this space
you know and everyone but but that's
cool because because then people it puts
you on the map
okay and start wanting to do deals with
you and sending you stuff so you got you
got a letting agent message you with a
deal
q's more the due diligence kind of guy
right the numbers guy which works well
together
but do you think there's a good you need
to have a balance of
taking action and putting yourself out
there
some people might do that without
knowing how to work out the numbers and
without proper training etc
but then other people might be so stuck
in the training and the due diligence
and the numbers
they don't take any action they don't
get anything done and it's kind of like
a balancing act
between between between the two i don't
know what you think no i think
yeah i think you're correct because we
kind of um yeah we cut like i said
before we bring
um you know different aspects to the
company and
like even though i thought i was out
there this guy's like on the totally
next level out there um but yeah he's
like i said like
if it wasn't for him getting like uh the
company out there we wouldn't get these
people who are interested but
um at the same time then he'll he'll
tell me about the numbers and then
he's the one that goes he's the one that
actually goes off
especially with the block when when you
found out about the block he was like uh
we should take 12 and i was like no no i
don't know if we're ready for 12.
yeah but if it wasn't for him to go now
to take action then
we wouldn't um we were not taking this
on so it's a good it's a good balance um
that we have and i think this is why
it's worked so well
how many properties have you got now
under control including the one you
bought
so they'll take it up to 20 yeah yeah 20
yeah that's great and when did you
realize because you got your first one
yeah you got your first one you've got a
second one you've got a third one
fifth you start and then you and then
we'll get on to the block
when did you realize this is working man
we're making money doing this rent to
rent actually
is a is a good thing when did you
realize that well after the first the
first one the first one the first one
yeah
what was it what was the feeling like
what happened you start getting bookings
oh yeah when we saw the bookings
constantly texting bringing each other
going wow look at the bookies we're
getting
but i forgot to mention we we got
another one in sheffield as well so we
got
this one and then we got one in
sheffield straight away so we ended up
having two
but with the sheffield one um we kind of
did everything
ourselves like with the cleaning and
everything so we wanted to learn
um not only all the good things but the
bad things as well with bad guests and
everything
which is kind of um helped us a lot yeah
but that one didn't really work out
too well um especially when coveted so
everything that we learned with the
sheffield one then we
um took it on to all our other
properties but yeah
that's what was the biggest what was the
biggest problem with the sheffield one
why did it not work
i think from what we've we know now it
was pretty much the
the the look of the property yeah yeah
yeah like this is brand new
you know yeah and if this was in
sheffield 100 i know this would work but
it was a bit dated
because you saw my you i think you were
copying my video yeah yeah welcome
lucas because i was in sheffield because
i i was living in shenfield at that time
so i was like oh i'm gonna try to get
one right on my doorstep
yeah but the thing is we didn't kind of
get everything
into that apartment yeah like so we
didn't wanna yeah
we're trying to um kind of um
shortcuts you know cut corners yeah
they're designed in there
you know you'll see them that they're
like this yeah you know spanky
yeah i'll tell you that it was it was a
used layout
yeah yeah yeah we cut corners which
showed
why it didn't work so we learned so much
yeah
so much and it was just a blessing that
our carlton house was doing so well
it would cover the cost yeah but when
they both hit we're like wow
yeah i mean yeah so you learn from it
right you've got to take rather than
take rather than take the loss you've
got to take the lesson
yeah and then so so that one didn't work
out what about the others generally oh
you just don't know
they're all doing really well so so we
got um yeah so we got that first
um one in in carlton road then we're
like okay
we'll go get another one so we've got
another one did the same thing corbin
wakefield
working well and then it just kind of
flowed from there like a domino effect
it's great and also at what point
because
would it be fair to say that in the
early stages of your property business
your wives were a bit unsure
i think you almost got divorced five
times so i was twice at this point
in trouble for planning that's without
telling it and then i'm gonna
why did you not tell your wife like do
you not think that the reason you guys
got into trouble and almost both got
divorced
was because you were doing stuff yeah
without saying anything
i mean i don't know it's a tough one i
think when you step out of the circle of
of the people you hang around right you
become a different person
in their eyes and say why are you doing
property do you actually know what
you're doing
you've never done property before and i
was like i've done sam's crash book
i've read these books
but um like you know for you to get you
know extraordinary results you need to
step out and you need to take action
well i was it was like coming out of our
comfort zone
and we're willing to kind of invest a
bit of our own money
into trying to make this work and they
didn't agree with it
you know because it was out of the
ordinary to do that and no one in our
circle
was doing that maybe you did the wrong
one maybe you did the right
thing by just doing it and not saying
because if you've tried to get
their permission they would have just
said no i think so so you had to beg for
forgiveness
i think so with me i think i needed to
do it
for them to didn't see like what
yeah it's like don't tell me what to do
just show me but it's a really tough one
i mean what would you say to somebody
that was worried about their partner
their wife their spouse whatever oh
don't do it don't
don't do what we did yeah what would you
do what would you recommend today
maybe get them to understand more about
um yeah
could you send them to a crash course
would they have come no no no
yeah yeah i think the one that pushed me
the most was like
okay after rugby yeah what am i gonna do
then i thought
well i don't want to go to a um you know
no offense to you know i don't want to
go in the factory and work in a factory
like i don't want to do that i don't
want to be told what to do how to do i
rather have something that's passive
income yeah and i think the big
thing you said is you work once you get
paid once
which is um active income yeah but if
you work once and get paid forever it's
passive income yeah and that's what the
goal is
and i think that will help me provide
for my family or our families
yeah and um it will serve our purpose
with our kids
and our wife but you know what your
wives now we have to just say
they're okay for anyone watching this
now they're thinking like what what's
that
talk to me about what the setup is now
well they're they're pushing us around
now
they're what they're posting
don't do this you don't know what you're
doing now they're in there like no you
don't know what you're doing now
we know what to do with these properties
right now so they were saying don't do
it now
here's how you do it yeah yeah yeah yeah
so they have
a big say in um which properties we take
yeah so now we take them and
they they're like they do the viewings
they do the viewings and they're like oh
no it just wouldn't work
and are they on the payroll
so they're on the payroll the properties
are doing well they're booming
you've got 1920 properties in total that
you are the own conversation control
with service departments um and i know i
always ask the question how much how
much profit you're making and you guys
said to me
off camera you're like it's hard to say
because we've we put a lot of money back
into business we
we're we're employed we take salaries
we've employed our wives
depends on the month but would it be
fair to say that if if rugby stopped now
you'd be okay
yeah yeah yeah like obviously i think
we'll like there's a we have a goal to
try and get
25 properties at the end of the year so
we're almost here yeah already and um we
know that
if we get 25 26 then we'll be able to
stop
you know if we wanted to to stop playing
and i know you'd never do that
no no we love right because you love it
too much i think we it's
also another lesson don't um see your
goals too low
yeah yeah so my new our new
my new goal i haven't told them yet but
this is me
i want to get 40 now you know she is so
much more left
is yeah yeah i mean exactly we're we're
we're in the first part of the year
still
you've almost hit your big goal yeah so
i'm 25. yeah um you're doing
ridiculously well i want to i want to
just find out like what what's the
strongest reason to do this you touched
on it but what's the strongest reason
why you're doing this
besides not wanting to finish rugby and
have to go and get a job
oh providing for our families i think
that's the the biggest thing is like
not like providing for our families but
also having the time to
spend with our family so like he said
before like
there's no disrespect to someone who
works in the factory but
we don't want to be able to we don't
want to go um spend nine to five
um a factory job and then not being able
to take my kids to school or
pick them up and not being able to spend
time with our families so we want to be
able to
um you know provide for our families
through property
and having having spending as much time
as possible as we can with them as well
it's pretty much the same as cue but in
terms of the cycle in my family
our families we're assam right born in
new zealand
live in australia but our families have
always worked
for someone yeah they've never owned a
business or
or been in property and if you look at
all the successful people around you
that's doing really really well in the
world
they own real estate so um yeah i just
want to try and break the cycle for my
kids so they don't have to do what i did
but they could actually see the bigger
picture and what life's all about
so yeah yeah family's big that's great
and you guys are great guys
and you know i love seeing people win
who
are good people you know and it's been
great seeing your journey over the last
few years
um you want to get 25 you want to get 40
now
what would be your best piece of advice
to someone maybe watching this maybe
if they're in the sports profession or
they're wanting to break into property
what would be your biggest advice to
someone that's wanting to get started
out
well my biggest advice is um like it
wolf anything it just comes down to hard
work and
the time you put into it um so like we
know with rugby if
you're not putting in the hard work you
won't see the results on the field so
that's practically the same as
as property so if you don't put in the
work and like
all the time into being successful in it
um you won't get the results um
and so that's how we started we went out
we started doing viewings and we knew we
were going to get loads of setbacks
yeah um so we i think we viewed about 50
yeah properties before we got our first
yes
but that's all part of the process and
it's all part of learning as the ground
workers
yes the groundwork and we started
reading loads of books
and so yeah we just put a lot of energy
and effort into
learning about property and i'm just
making sure that um
yeah we have as much knowledge as
possible and also
networking meeting a lot of people yeah
that are that are willing to
kind of help us out throughout our
journey because like like
like you said you won't you won't come
across many successful people who have
you know been successful by themselves
there's always people there to help you
out
yeah and that is the same for us as well
that's probably my number one like
if you see something you like and then
you you enjoy
go straight to the person who's doing it
and living it yeah because
you're going to get more advice from
that person than someone that's never
done it before
yeah and sometimes they've never done it
before person is your family
right so a lot of the people that tell
you what to do
be careful yeah you know whatever
whatever whatever it's like well hang on
have you done this yeah are you
experiencing
straight to the beginning yeah so like
for me for me to be the best back rower
in rugby
i'm going talking to the best back rows
in rugby league without going to someone
that's playing
like at a different level yeah and the
thing is we've been property this whole
community
yeah i've been just if you've yeah
footballers are doing it you know and i
think that if you're right guys it's so
important to get around other people
yeah
um that are that are doing it because if
you just if you just
all the time here and be careful be
careful um people holding you back
it can be it can be really lonely yeah
and it's been great i know we've been
chatting on what's happened
a lot man well i feel like i did that
with you yeah i knew that you're in the
game so i thought well
samuel how do you do this you'd ride
back and that's crazy
like now for me for us is one of our
goals is impact
and if we can um you know have a major
impact in
in the um community or you know people
around us that's part of our goals
yeah obviously marriage is the next one
so our lives are very important
and then income so income is our
business how we're going to provide for
our family so
yeah impact marriage and uh income and
you guys got a lot of kids
oh he's got four you've got four and
you're about to have three
well no you're about to have one more
you've got two already two
when is your next one joe um no
no yeah today a week in a week yeah but
you literally told me you were literally
like i'll do the interview but i might
have to leave halfway through
you know depending on how things go yeah
so yeah any time now checking graphics
congratulations you've got you've got
you've got a third kid about to come god
willing
you've got four kids yeah crazy
your wives must be busy as ever yeah
yeah do they love property now are they
glad that you made the plunge
yeah 100 but it's good that they um
they're on board now oh yeah they they
do a lot of work for us now
like now that we've got them on board um
it's
kind of helped massively for the
business um and yeah a lot of the stuff
that
like we we can't do in the background
they've jumped on it
yeah another thing as well as seeing
from your first deal you said you got 36
return on investment on your first deal
that you bought yeah because just a
straightforward buy to that
um but then you moved into doing renter
rents where you're controlling
properties
now also your now you've got a working
system in that you're bringing in
investors and which is giving you an
infinite return
yeah you know you're sharing the profits
with other people what why
why are you doing that why did you make
the decision because i know you've said
to me as well
um q you've been like i want to prove
that you can do this with no money
yeah talk to me about that no it's just
like um yeah because
i think the biggest another thing that
we wanted to prove is
to become successful in property with
pretty much no money obviously you have
to put money in um to start off with our
first deal but
now we haven't had to put any money in
because we're just constantly putting it
back into the business
yeah but um yeah like once we once we
tell the strategy to
people we know or investors and we tell
them how our property is doing and
like who's staying in our properties and
people are willing to
invest money into to the houses that we
we we get yeah and then that's so cool
which has been awesome
that's so cool and also as well like if
people want to connect is it best to
connect with jesse on instagram
oh he's the instagram man he's the dude
he's the social media that's how we
often speak
yeah how do we follow how do we how do
we how do we connect with you guys how
do we follow you
well we've got childline property yeah
on instagram which is just trial and
property yeah
and then um obviously jesse center
baby
no no i just office instagram yeah
yeah yeah and it's so cool that you're
doing that though because you know a lot
of people might think oh it's easy for
you you've got a good career your sports
people you can just dump your money into
property but the fact that you've
actually
finally started off by investing your
money but then actually let's push the
boundaries on the strategies here let's
let's try rental rents and let's bring
other
other people over invested in i think
it's amazing and i know part of the
reason you did that was not just the
challenges because your wives were going
crazy because you kept spending money on
i just bought some furniture i just
bought a house and just bought a course
i just went and they're like what what
yeah
i made you a joke really but you said
that you would have almost been more
forgiving if you just said i've got a
gambling addiction
i got a gambling addiction leave me
alone really you're buying like you're
buying furniture
sometimes we needed blankets and stuff
and linen for a company
yeah if i took 300 quid i could just say
i put it on a horse and
lost it but really it's for them
so funny another thing is what you
talked about right the beginning of the
interview said about how important your
faith was now you know that i'm a
christian as well
um you know and and my faith is really
important part of why i got into
business in the first place
why did you bring that up at the
beginning and why is that so important
um i just think you know without my
lord jesus i wouldn't play rugby yeah
and um that was probably the first
purpose you know he
he's given me this talent and i
shouldn't waste it and if i can um
get in front of people and inspire then
um i'm serving
my purpose yeah yeah yeah that's so good
man
guys it's a real pleasure to know you as
friends
um as well as as well as peers in
property
uh final final words of wisdom for
someone watching
go ahead kier ah funnel was a wisdom um
so
our fingers um never let anyone
tell you you can't do it um put your
mind to it and
be willing to put in the hard work that
you need to put in to
become successful and you're always
gonna um
you know face setbacks by then it's what
you do after those sit backs that come
yeah great stuff man well hey thank you
so much
what a pleasure we've been we've been
talking about this day for a long time
yeah we have we have
finally made it real finally made it
real
hey guys if you enjoyed the interview do
us a favor
do everybody a favor just hit the like
button smash
like drop a comment in for jesse and q
you want to see more interviews like
this i got over 100 winners on the
wednesday interviews you can check them
out right up here
don't forget to subscribe over here and
i look forward to meet new person one
day god bless
see you next time
you can't hold me down